[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une amie que Paris vient
d'accueillir en la personne de la Grande
Duchesse Charlotte de Luxembourg son
premier geste fut de se recueillir en
compagnie du général de Gaulle sur le
tombeau du soldat inconnu
[Musique]
bien des liens historiques unissent les
deux pays dans l'édification de l'Europe
le Luxembourg qui abrita la première
communauté européenne celle du charbon
et de l'acier a joué un rôle éminemment
tactique
votre invitation a pu dire la Grande
Duchesse au chef de l'État est un grand
geste qui reconnaît au Luxembourg sa
place en Europe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pékin vient de célébrer le 14e
anniversaire de la République populaire
chinoise
pour la quatrième fois la grande parade
d'octobre ne comportait pas d'autres
évocations militaires que les
mitraillettes des miliciennes et les
bazooka des miliciens
[Musique]
dans la tribune officielle ou avait pris
place Mao tsetum chwen lie et les
leaders chinois ont noté l'absence des
Russes
c'est au milieu d'une débauche de fleurs
et de banderoles qu'un demi-million de
personnes ont ainsi défilé devant la
porte de la paix céleste
au Sud Vietnam sur lequel se sont
concentrés depuis quelques temps les
feux de l'actualité internationale les
électeurs ont voté pour désigner les 123
nouveaux députés de l'Assemblée
nationale
ah Saigon où l'on évalué la
participation électorale à 85%, le
président Vienne est allé aux urnes
confiants la nouvelle Assemblée contrat
du reste dans ses rangs sa jolie est
terrible belle-sœur madame new qui
effectue une tournée de propagande en
faveur du régime Diem et que à Paris les
tomates et les pots de peinture de
quelques manifestants laissaient de
glace
[Musique]
je suis
la souris de cette campagne car j'ai
décidé de ne pas me laisser intimider
mais
au contraire de la dénoncer je n'ai
jamais dit non plus que les jeunes
officiers américains au Vietnam sont des
soldats de fortune aventuriers et sa
beauté moi jugé sur je ne sais quel
rapporte rapport serait injuste cruel
incompréhensible choquant et extrêmement
offensant surtout quand toutes mes
conférences de presse sont enregistrées
vous le voyez
l'Indonésie pour tous ces balises Bornéo
Sumatra Java et leurs images aimables et
pittoresques comme toujours la réalité
est différente l'Indonésie c'est 100
millions d'habitants qui essayent de
vivre plus ou moins bien sur 1300 îles
dont la surface égale quatre fois la
France
c'est le pays de la mousson c'est-à-dire
6 mois d'inondations qui ravage les
rizières et six mois de sécheresse ou
plus rien ne pousse pour vivre mieux
l'Indonésie de la vie sans souci et des
bains sans façon à grands besoins
d'accroître son potentiel industriel et
agricole ainsi est né le projet du
barrage de Jacky Lure qui sera le plus
grand du monde et pour lequel le
gouvernement a indonésien a fait appel à
des techniciens français
équipé de turbines produisant 700
millions de kilowatts heure par an il
sera en même temps un grand barrage de
retenue d'une capacité de 3 milliards de
mètres cubes qui serviront à
l'irrigation on atteint de ces travaux
qui occupent 7000 ouvriers indonésiens
sous la conduite d'ingénieurs français
une récolte de riz supplémentaires par
an
aux images d'une Indonésie
conventionnelle se substitue aujourd'hui
celle de l'Indonésie des réalités de
demain
[Musique]
un siècle a passé depuis qu'un belge de
Paris Étienne Lenoir créa la première
voiture dont le moteur du membreft
utilisait un mélange des tanins à base
de vapeur de pétrole
l'allumage était provoqué par une
étincelle électrique éclatante entre
deux fils de platine
et ça marchait
Alphonse Beau de Rochas perfectionnale
invention il eut l'idée de comprimer le
mélange d'éthanol avant de l'enflammer
édifions ainsi la théorie du moteur à 4
temps mais il fallut attendre 26 ans
pour que les Allemands Daimler et mebach
utilisent ces théories pour créer le
moteur à 4 temps et ce fut aux deux
filles en français qui achetèrent à
Denner le brevet de son moteur et c'est
ainsi que d'une part messieurs Panhard
et Levasseur myrte au point dans leurs
usines d'Ivry à Paris la première
automobile à moteur à quatre temps
tandis que d'autres parts on en faisait
autant chez Peugeot c'était en 1891
[Musique]
les voitures électriques ou les voitures
à vapeur représentées par les deux dions
boutons et les serpolets étaient
condamnés on le vit bien lors des
grandes compétitions sur route que ça te
juger très vite les voitures à pétrole
en 1900 la France berceau de cette
industrie comptait déjà 299 véhicules en
circulation en 1901
5386 en 1913 108000 temps lointain dans
les images nous arrachent un sourire
d'atteindrisme avec leur peau de bique
leur cache poussière et leurs volets
le premier code de la route il convient
de le signaler n'a quitte en 1899 il
portait la signature du président Émile
Loubet
cette ambiance d'une époque révolue le
Tout-Paris a pu s'y plonger à l'occasion
du 50e Salon de l'Auto car c'est à la
fois aux fans de l'automobile
d'aujourd'hui et d'hier que c'est ouvert
sur les Champs-Élysées le pub Renault
4000 personnes ayant fait un pèlerinage
au temps héroïques en compagnie de
Monsieur Dreyfus président directeur
général de la régie vive montant de
réchuga Robinson et de Maurice Chevalier
[Musique]
mais au 50e salon 100 ans apprennent
l'invention de le noir ce ne sont pas
les souvenirs du passé qui est venu
chercher la folie nombrable des
conducteurs et candidats conducteurs
d'aujourd'hui une vision des voitures de
demain peut-être aux formes
vertigineuses
un aperçu sur le nouveau moteur rotatif
version révolutionnaire de notre quatre
temps éprouvé
[Musique]
avant tout c'est aux voitures de grandes
séries que la foule a porté son
attention faire chez Peugeot par exemple
la connaissance du nouveau vilebrequin à
5 paliers qui équipent la 404
encore une fois la dernière née des
usines de Sochaux et vérifier la plus
grande habitabilité des places arrières
[Musique]
ou encore apprécier le confort de la
berline équipée du nouveau moteur diesel
1948 cm3
on ne négligera pas de jeter un regard
attentif aux pneumatique et les mains
importants de la sécurité dont les
derniers nés se prévalent de leur longue
durée
on appréciera qu'après la R8 Renaud
équipe aujourd'hui la dauphine de frein
à disque et de boîte automatique on
surveillera le détail car on est devenu
difficile depuis le noir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour ces dizaines de milliers de
Parisiens Longchamp avec le Prix de
l'Arc de Triomphe c'est le rendez-vous
de la fortune pour des millions d'autres
Français installés devant leur poste
radio ou de télévision c'est l'énorme
suspense au bout duquel vont pleuvoir à
gogo les millions de la Loterie
Nationale bref les 15 chevaux du Grand
Prix ont entamé à toute bride le galop
de l'espoir un seul d'entre eux a droit
au triomphe un triomphe doré sur tranche
près de 1 million 63 pour le gagnant que
voici et qui se dégage dès le début de
la dernière ligne droite
[Musique]
il fonce vers la gloire et vers la
fortune
puisque riz est bien décidément le
meilleur cheval européen de la saison
[Musique]